president Trump signaling he's open to
easing federal guidelines urging
Americans right now to limit social
contact and largely stay home
what could the medical fallout be dr.
Peter Hotez is Dean of the National
School of Tropical Medicine and
professor of pediatrics molecular
virology and microbiology at Baylor
College of Medicine he has been a
frequent guest for us and he joins us
this morning on the phone doctor good
morning good morning talk about the
balance that the president has to meet
right now in terms of getting this
economy going again but doing it in a
way that does not spike the number of
deaths yeah I mean the president's in a
tight spot and you know he's dealing
with something that's unprecedented
here's the situation the reason you're
doing the social distancing it's because
you want to avoid a huge number of
patients in any particular city that's
being affected from coming into the
hospital at once I mean this is what's
happening in New York City right now I
mean hospitals are being overwhelmed by
kovat positive patient patients in the
ICU patients in the hospital and it's
and and you have health care workers
getting sick at the same time so it's
it's very easy for a group of hospitals
gets completely overwhelmed to the point
where they can't take care of patients
or by social distancing you sort of
spread that out over time and make it
manageable yeah i but I understand why
the president is frustrated and a lot of
Americans are frustrated and want to
restart the economy he's doing a lot of
things at the legislative level you know
he's pressing hard on all those fronts
my take on it is this we're just being
now what the full impact of the epidemic
looks like in New York City let's let
this play out let's see what this looks
like in a few more weeks and what we
really witnessed in hospital systems get
overwhelmed and let's bring that and
let's get that victory under our belt
terms of controlling it then we can
reassess and say okay ha let's go what
went right what went wrong and then make
a decision whether we want to relax some
of the social distancing but don't do it
now here's the president yesterday
talking about that
and how different areas of the country
have different rates of people being
exposed to coronavirus watch you have
areas which are troubling and we'll be
working with the governor and the mayor
and everybody else on those spots but at
the same time at a certain point we have
to get open and we have to be we have to
get moving we don't want to lose these
companies so we don't want to lose these
workers and on top of that dr. Burks
yesterday at the same news conference
dr. Hotez said that the best estimate
right now of the mortality rate here in
the United States is 0.7 or 0.8 percent
as in less than 1% now every life
matters and you don't want to minimize
any of them but when the mortality rate
is that low what is the balance what
would be your advice to the president if
say he's trying to make this decision
this coming weekend ahead of the
expiration of the 15 days to slow the
spread so what I would would tell the
president mr. president know the
mortality rate you know that may sound
like a low rate in fact it's about five
or six times higher than influenza and
what's more it's not just older
individuals we have a what we're seeing
about the 44 the Centers for Disease
Control we're seeing about a third of
the patients who are hospitalized under
the age of 44 44 and and even though
they're not necessarily dying there
their lives are being saved because
they're in ICU being taken care of and
the risk I mean like Italy right now is
you have so many patients and I use that
they just can't take care of them all
yeah and you're starting to see high
mortality so I would say look let's get
one public health victory under our belt
here in terms of what's going on in New
York maybe we're looking at another
month and then and then reassess and I
agree you know we can't we can't stop
our economy in perpetuity sure or even
here even for two years god I think I
think if you do it now while the numbers
are still steeply climbing in New York
and remember now we're seeing a new
epidemic coming up on in New Orleans we
don't really fully understand how this
epidemic is going to play out it's a
brand new virus pathogen give it another
month
and carefully array all of that I've got
30 seconds doctor in terms of mortality
rates you talk about we've got to learn
from Italy we've got to learn from South
Korea from China we've been looking at
all these places around the world
Germany right now the mortality rate is
0.4%
and a lot of doctors are looking at
trying to figure it out my understanding
is that a lot of young people at the
beginning of the outbreak in Germany got
it and showed very mild symptoms what
are we learning from Germany I think
there's that but I think also it's the
fact that the Germans got on top of it
very early and started testing early and
the hospitals were ready and they were
did it in a way where their hospitals
were not going to get overwhelmed
because that's when the mortality rates
go up if you look at the difference even
say between Wuhan and central China and
other parts of China it's because the
hospitals got overwhelmed they can't
take care of the patients optimally the
lot of the doctors are getting sick and
that makes the difference between 0.6
percent say what we saw in in Korea
versus 3 or 4 or 5 percent then and it's
all about and making certain but making
certain of hospitals can handle that
surge doctor we haven't really shown
that New York can do that yep pardon me
doctor we really appreciate your time
dr. Peter Hotez been a voice of calm
throughout this appreciate you coming
back